so I'll put vintage in and I'll say
whether I want the AI to do a lot of
work or a little bit of work when it
comes to creating his music T Peters is
stranger to using art
Elegance in the process
[Music]
not only does AI help him mix and master
songs he also uses it when creating
cover arts and promotional materials AI
for me
is uh it's the perfect assistant for the
tiles that we're in right now I can use
the AI tool to kind of help me kind of
get generate ideas so that when I do get
the money to invite my friends or about
other partners to help me I can easily
just show them what I did by myself and
then they can add their own touch to
what I've done
tea is not the only one youth music
surveyed nearly 3 000 creatives across
the UK they found 63 of young people
incorporate AI in Creative processes but
the trend reverses through age groups
with AI only being used by 19 of those
over 55.
the charity believes AI is pivotal in
helping improve accessibility Within the
Music Industry the AI is being used in
an assistive way to help with press
releases writing lyrics writing
marketing copy and to do all those
things that somebody more privileged
would be able to pay for but young
creatives doing it for themselves have
found a way that AI can help them and
really overcome the barriers that they
face
but the use of AI is met with concern
concern around what it takes away from
music
supposed to come from sort of the heart
or the soul or when when you come up
with a rhythm is supposed to be a flash
of inspiration if someone's doing it for
you or a machine is doing it for you
it's like why am I making music in the
first place
[Music]
those using AI say it doesn't affect
their creativity it simply allows them
to focus on creating the best tracks
they can I shazid Sky News